what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends yep
hey hello hello everybody
you want to start the show sophia yeah
fine i'll just go into it because
someone's really annoying me
i'm not in a good mood right now yeah
i'm going to start the show sophia is in
a very you're like a little sour [ __ ] i
don't know why
it's affecting me i'm gonna try to block
that you know what it was weird i woke
up this morning
totally fine like jumping around i
worked out we hung out with the new
puppy which we'll talk about for a bit
later but
yeah i don't know i came into the car
everyone's sucked at driving the weather
is horrible
i dropped the light in mud there's mud
all over my jeans
oh my god you said i look pale do i look
like casper
so there we go and now i'm just in a bad
mood so you're going to blame me for
your bad mood
and now also sistine likes to edge me on
so she just
acts even more happy than she normally
is if i go
[Music]
take a breath you got it one more
okay transactions just so much worse
[Laughter]
are triggered yeah why is it um when the
weather in la gets cloudy
everyone just forgets how to drive or
how about is mercury in retrograde right
now yeah it actually is
all right there we go this is the last
one of the year
oh it is yeah so i think it's been
totally powerful it's really powerful
because it's messing me up because we
just came back from florida visiting our
dad he's on set working
it was so good to see him you guys he's
working in atlanta right now finishing a
movie that got shut down
before covid and now it's starting back
up again and we haven't seen him in
a long time so we got to sort of meet
him halfway and it was lovely
to catch up with the old fire i mean
other than the fact that people in
florida said that this is the worst
weather they've seen all year
yeah we got a hurricane yeah hurric no
do you know when raindrops are not like
the tiny ones they're like the big drops
when raindrops aren't on roses and
whispers why
are you doing that that has nothing to
do with our time that's the mercury it's
making me angry no it was
it was definitely horrible weather but
great seeing him we took a cover test
every two days because the studio
obviously
wanted to make sure that he was okay but
along
that we we actually had this
conversation in the car
where we met these two girls and they're
super fun super cool to hang out with
but
i don't know why i feel like so
anti-social meeting people are making
new friends
yeah why is it that there's such anxiety
i don't know if this is anyone else or
just sophia and i
but we're so bad at putting ourselves
out there to make new friends
especially because all of my friends are
all over the country at college
and yours are all graduated sort of
dispersed out everywhere
so you you kind of have to make friends
or else absolutely you won't ever get
out and
the stress behind even just going out is
scarier than doing it
so well do you think it is covered no
it was before but for me it's the idea
of
starting up a new friendship with
someone is so scary but then when you're
in that situation
it's totally fine and they're nice and
now we have two new girlfriends it was
funny because then before
someone's like oh like there's girls
coming we're like oh no we have to make
friends with people and then it just
like it builds up in your
head that it's going to be this like
horrible experience and then obviously
these girls are super nice and
um we're also outgoing people we're
definitely not ones that shy away from
anybody
but i don't know why just that build up
gives me
anxiety yeah social anxiety whatever
well
well well we're friends with them now so
we're fine oh
will i know you'll know this okay is the
new borat
movie coming out this weekend
you thought he knew okay we got a
naughty naught over there yes i totally
knew
and it is oh my god welcome to kakistan
she loves this i don't know in the car
she was telling me how much i love bull
rats
actually technically when this airs it
will have already come out last weekend
right so it's coming out so we better
what else does borat say
i don't know um i know that he what was
the other character he played that was i
love
pamela anderson she is very beautiful
american woman yeah like now you're
sounding more
like the guy from despicable me not as
much
oh my god sofia you guys sophie and i
think
that we're so good at accents we are
good at accents i would like to think
i'm good at accents so seems really good
at doing um um edna from edna mode yeah
from incredible yes but sophia can do
um what's her character's name jennifer
coolidge and um legally blonde
oh legally blonde yeah no okay
i'm taking the dog dumbass
was that good i don't know i got nervous
my voice sounded higher we do it
dog one um oh you look like the fourth
of july
god i want a hot dog that makes me want
a hot dog real bad
it's not that good i don't know i think
it sounds so funny and great but
okay you do yours dude the baby has
powers from unknown
do it to it it's not good it is good
okay i need to not laugh don't look at
me
do you guys know what i'm talking about
incredibles 2 edna mode she discovers
that jack-jack has powers
and scene
the baby has powers
that was so so fun
oh my god i love what she does what's
his name though the guy from despicable
me
first i take the moon first i go to the
moon second i grab moon i shrink moon
and third i bring moon back to space
earth
do you think i'm the worst at doing
british accents i know oh sophia's
british i'm not that bad
i'm not that bad hello my name is molly
i'm from
essex i'm 23 years young i want a bird
that's fit
let's go to the pub mates oh i've heard
way worse from
major movie actors she literally thought
you're being so generous because that
was trash no that wasn't
please let me know if i sound
that bad that sistine is giving me [ __ ]
every single day
just mug off mate
[Laughter]
i think it's because i'm getting hyped
up by him that my accent's great and
also giving her confidence to do this
also the fact that we have on recording
you doing the group
impression is my all right
all right let's talk about hey go first
let's talk about
great song all right um you guys know
the drill we're back at it again with
our favorite
cbd talks you know sophia and i we're in
our 20s
we like to drink we like to go out
indoors
at the moment but you know what happens
when you drink too much
hangovers so you get that grogginess you
get that laziness you just feel
like absolute crap the next day and
there's nothing worse than no remedy to
help it out
so thank the lords for
cbd talks i'm serious this product will
change your life
it is the first cbd based hangover
remedy
that targets the physical and mental
aspects of a hangover
oh also it has hemp so it'll make you
feel calmer
alleviate pain nausea and get rid of all
that toxic
alcohol in your body but it doesn't make
you feel high because it has zero
percent thc
so what sophie and i like to do is take
a dose before bed
and another one in the morning if we
need it which normally we don't because
one will do the trick
depends how much fun you had and it
makes us feel
a thousand times better the next day we
have a special
20 off discount for our beautiful
unwaxed listeners go to
shop.getcbdtalks.com
shop.getcbdtalks that's cbdtox.com
and use code unwaxed at checkout they
offer a 30 money back guarantee
so you have nothing to lose trying it
out again go to shop.getcbdtalks.com
and use code unwaxed for 20 percent off
you can also find them on instagram
at cbd talks remedy let us know what you
think
and we're back with another
segment of the unsolicited advice
segment with your two favorite sisters
sophia and sustain all right
um again if you guys want us to answer
your questions leave them in the rating
review section
of our unwaxed podcast on apple thank
you so much
so sistine chose one i don't actually
know what it is so i have one or two
we'll do there's one quick one i think
we should we need to let's just do the
quick one
all right this one said hey y'all i just
started listening to your podcast and
had a question for you
as a guy what is the best way to slide
into a girl's dms
i've heard a ton of people talk about
this and just wanted to get your opinion
interesting okay i have
from experience of guys sliding in
because that happens
not very often but when it does i like
when someone
responds to a story and writes a caption
so they'll send me my story and write
something related to that
that's the most casual coolest way just
to get in there
another way is to get verified i'm
kidding i'm kidding
i'm kidding no but um it does stop
laughing it's a joke okay but it's true
it's no
that does help but no um i would i have
to agree with that i like when guys
respond to my story or they write a
funny
joke i do think guys have to put in a
little bit more effort with what they
say
girls can kind of write like hey or
whatever yeah
hey what's up or yo yeah but
keep it interesting i think that's right
if you're not answering a story
write something that will instantly
catch their eye like a question
yeah start the conversation as if you're
already in the middle of the
conversation
so don't start with hey or how are you
start with
you know i love punchline a knock knock
joke something just to catch her eye
something like if a guy one guy wrote to
me who would win the fight like a
thousand
kittens or a one t-rex and then
and then you have a full-blown
conversation so do that if you want to
get a girl's attention
okay we have another one this is from a
girl named kate
what's up kate thanks for listening she
wrote
do you guys think that friends with
benefits
is worth it
in my dreams yes okay
according to justin timberlake and mila
kunis
friends with benefits looks like the
most incredible
thing ever or no strings attached with
that it just looks great
it just looks great because in the
movies they make it look
fun and the sex looks like it's amazing
and you guys are just on the same page
but you're still having your
independence and then you have no
feelings with that person but you're
getting all the benefits if you can
figure that out
dm me and let me know the secret because
i personally think
when you have sex with someone you're
gonna have some sort of connection with
them
whether you don't want it or you do and
someone always catches feelings yeah and
then that means at the end of the day if
you both aren't on the same page with
those feelings someone is gonna get hurt
and it's just sort of a disaster waiting
to happen
but if it works i'm sure it's a lot of
fun
i definitely think if you're going into
something that you don't want it to be
so serious
just make it known put it out there
really early on because
then when you can see maybe someone's
catching feelings you guys can have that
open conversation going this is not what
we planned
yes but you must create the rules you
gotta create early on
because if you don't you know what rules
are meant to be broken oh okay
do it cross the line let me know don't
do it text us if it works
but realistically maybe stay away from
that if you're trying to
still be their friend afterwards see
this is why this podcast you're going to
get one opinion
well it's unsolicited because we really
don't know obviously i
think that it just i don't know on it
it's hard to say
i'm like exasperated so we are about to
bring on
these two badass women katie and lauren
they have a super cool company
called higher dose and they create all
these really cool products with
infrared sauna one's a nutritionist a
wellness coach we're really excited sort
of just to
pick their brains thank you guys for
joining us today
thank you for having us well i just want
to start out with
i think your backgrounds and both of
what you did before is amazing so what
motivated you guys from
to leave this lucrative career and
decide to open up these sauna spas
i didn't actually leave my career um
just my background is in
i'm a nutritionist and health coach so i
was actually working at a health and
wellness startup
before higher dose and was introduced
introduced to the infrared sauna from
some of the most amazing doctors
naturopaths
and fitness people and it was like this
like underground secret that no one
really knew about which
was quite interesting and actually at
the time when i googled infrared saunas
there was only one location in new york
city
and that was the colonic studio in the
basement
and it was like an awful experience and
yeah it was it was such a dodgy weird
place so
uh when i went and tried it i was
immediately hooked
my skin was glowing i slept through the
night i felt calm and connected
what oh wait i need this asap yeah it
was all about right now like no sleep
exactly it's one of those treatments
that you try and you immediately get it
you're like wow like you don't have to
do six sessions in order to get the
benefits it's immediate
right so those are the quick quick
results from doing infrared are there
any long-term results that you've
noticed
i mean there's a ton it depends so the
quick term you're gonna see
great skin calm and connected you're
gonna sleep through the night
but long-term the detox it detoxes you
seven times more than any traditional
sweating
[Music]
radiation environmental pollutant inside
your fat cells so
from a detox aspect i don't think
there's anything else on the market that
can quite compare to the infrared sauna
and then in terms of like anti-aging
benefits it's amazing for your skin
your skin looks glowy dewy it can build
collagen
so i mean just from skin benefits and
anti-aging it's
by far one of our favorite beauty
biohacks out there
um and then just in terms of like
overall wellness
i mean you're going to feel amazing and
the more you do it and the more toxins
you get out and more sleepy
that you get the more of the benefits
that you're going to see
wow so wait what is biohacking by the
way i feel like people don't always like
they don't really know the word i know
that it's like the idea of using
science and biology to hack your bodies
but how do you go into that more
i kind of look at it as like like uh you
know like cheating on your homework in
school it's like cheating on your
health i don't know that's a perfect
comparison i totally get it now
but like for instance like a iv drip
right if you get your vitamins through
an iv drip you get
like a hundred times more than you would
get if you were just like eating kale
salads all the day
right so i i kind of look at it as like
a cheat almost but
for a good purpose so it's it's not like
a bad kind of cheating
i love that and we've sort of been
always surrounded with these really cool
technologies living in l.a there's
always like something well especially
because my dad
um he's an action movie star so he's
always sort of in a lot of pain so
we have an infrared sauna in our home
and i know yeah
well it's crazy because like i never
used we never use it and now
i'm so silly that it's i've just kind of
blind eye to it but he
he seriously stands by and i've read as
well you guys have such sort of a cult
following like
a lot of celebrities influencers
athletes have stood behind higher dose
so what's that
reaction been like since starting it
it's been helpful launching our brand in
new york city because we're based like
you know right in the bowery right in
soho where a lot of like influencers
celebrities entertainment professionals
live and um i think they sometimes often
will
lead the way on health innovations
because it's pretty much their job to
look and feel their best at all times
and they're willing to
devote a lot of time and effort into
that and a lot of money um so actually
like
many of our first clients were very well
known celebrities i remember even
you know like four and a half years ago
right when we launched i was working the
desk and leonardo dicaprio randomly came
in
that little no name yeah i was
definitely not prepared for that
um but you know fun story to tell
michelle williams was coming in a lot
busy phillips and they're just you know
it
was
it's just great to see like their
gratitude for something that
makes them feel better you know they're
just kind of like us in a way and
need to de-stress and relax so
definitely um
that the product is relatable like
amongst
socioeconomic and different status
levels everybody loves it
well i think everyone wants to feel good
and i'm such a believer in connecting
your mind to your body so if your body
doesn't feel right for l for me
mentally i'm not right so i love that
you know higher doses sort of releasing
these happy chemicals
in your body and and you you said before
you get to feel this sort of euphoric
feeling without having to get high which
is something that safina don't
partake in so this is this is incredible
that you guys are doing this
so thank you so since we're all in
quarantine and everyone's sort of been
locked up which this is probably the
best time to even use this
yeah say if you don't have an infrared
mat or a sauna nearby
what are some ways that you can keep up
your health being
in the comfort of your own home totally
i think one of the best
hacks in terms of if you don't have any
access to infrared would be
get out in the sun at least for i would
say 20 to 30 minutes
without sunscreen on and absorb vitamin
d and take in
you know the infrared rays because
infrared is in the sun too as well
so it's on the invisible light spectrum
and it's the exact same technology
that's in the sun
that's what infrared is so it warms up
your body
it's very healing it's very soothing
it's why you feel so good in sunshine
so i would definitely say if anyone's
listening out there and doesn't have
access to infrared
definitely do that if it's a sunny day
go outside get some vitamin d
and soak in those infrared rays and
that's how you release serotonin which
is a happy chemical which is
um in the s in dose so dopamine oxytocin
serotonin endorphins it's a big happy
chemical for you
um you want to make sure that you're you
know getting a big dose of serotonin and
that's how you
combat seasonal affective disorder as
well so oh that's perfect because i know
cece and i she takes cold showers and i
love to do like cell phone fat drainage
massages just like help with bloating
and everything so that's just another
additional thing people can just do
day to day to make them feel better do
you guys have any favorite products that
people that you you guys use
day to day that has changed your life
tons
like what would you say is probably like
the cult favorite like the three things
you probably use every single day that
you can highly suggest everyone else to
use i really love
uh this oil brand called gibba poa it's
a it's a
body oil um that first of all it smells
like nothing else on the market
and i get more compliments when i wear
that body oil than even like lalabo
or fragrances and it really just i think
taking the time to put on body oil for
like five to ten minutes a day
after a shower there's something about
it that really energizes your cells
uh and i just totally agree with that it
gives me such a mood boost so i love
that i use it all the time
um i actually stopped drinking coffee a
few months ago and i've been loving
like um hold on hold on
i still i still can't do that one i
can't i get migraines if i don't drink
coffee
are you a tea drinker yeah so i well for
a while i was no caffeine at all and
then i
recently um started drinking matcha and
maca
oh good for you i'm jealous but yeah no
it's
it's been good because i think it's it's
less aggressive than
um coffee so i i don't feel like those
crazy highs and then the crashes i just
i just feel like a more
stable energy um and it still gives you
that like ritual of like drinking
something warm and comforting in the
morning so
yeah get that source of energy from the
infrared saunas and blankets
totally you absolutely do um so those
are my go-to's these days but i'm sure
lauren has a much longer list than i do
and then the last thing is just red
light therapy i don't know if any of you
ladies are doing like red light masks
oh i've done it one time and it has
fixed my skin but i
just haven't continued it because i
don't have a red light mask so what does
that mean we are launching a red light
mask
wow there we go yeah it's the perfect
add-on to your sauna blanket or your mat
um but red light is amazing anti-aging
builds collagen increases blood flow
circulation
it repairs the skin it's an amazing
light that's
all around good for your health and
beauty and ours has infrared in it too
as well
so you'll get the amazing skin benefits
of the infrared press plus red light
there let me
break the bank with all these
do you guys have any secrets for sleep
because i know you guys seem like you
know so much about like tips and tricks
of how to
help that and i feel like a lot of our
listeners have written in like
sleeping hacks do you guys have any like
products you use or like
rituals you do before bed yeah there's a
device that lauren and i both got
interested and
introduced to earlier this year called
the chili pad
and it basically lets you control
the temperature of your bed so um
you can go anywhere from like 50 degrees
to
100 and personally and i think most
people like to have like a really cool
um sleeping environment so i've been
using that
to just like turn the heat down and
just feel really like cool when i go to
bed so i find that helps me
oh so nice cooling your body
like i'm someone that wouldn't think
that i would want to be cold when
sleeping and
it doesn't do that actually it does
fight the opposite i don't know if
you've ever woken up in the middle of
the night and you're really hot
yeah yes you've had a couple drinks and
then you wake up and you're like so hot
you can't sleep
yeah that is non-existent with this
chili pad
it just keeps your body to a cooler
temperature
so you can sleep deep and it's like it
you don't feel cold at all if anything
you just don't get hot and that's the
secret to the trick
i realized like i flipped my pillows
every time i get too hot just because
the other side is cooler so i guess it's
kind of a similar
thing except this obviously works way
better yeah it's just the materials that
the pillows and mattress
um use or like synthetic your body
degrees so you just like get really
really hot um
at night and that's what kind of wakes
you up and doesn't let you sleep deeply
oh my gosh that sounds incredibly cool
no pun you intended definitely was
really lame i'm sorry
um yeah you guys know so much about
about all these biohacking
can you give us one method or
biohack that you found actually benefits
you in no way that
was a trend and one that really has
changed your life i think infrared
might be the winner on that but is there
something that people are doing that
simply just has like cryotherapy or one
of those things
okay so um ketogenic diet so one thing
to know ladies about the biohacking
world is it is male dominated
and the issue is is that most of the
studies and tests that they do
are on men so you you know go into it
thinking
you're going to get the same results but
you end up not because they don't do
um the studies on women so um
you have to really like know what you're
getting yourself into and the thing is
it's all trial so you're just supposed
to like try it out but
listen to your body if your body is
telling you that it doesn't feel good
your energy levels are good
not good you're not sleeping as well you
know you know what it feels like when
something's not making you feel good
yeah i would just immediately um you
know stop so my example for that is the
ketogenic diet
which a lot of men thrive on which is a
high fat diet
and no fruit and i did that for like
literally like three years just pushing
through because
it made me like super lean i had no fat
on my body and i thought i was looking
good but
meanwhile it wasn't nourishing for my
hormones yeah right
i like literally had hormone issues for
like
i would say like six months afterwards
no way liver was in overdrive and it
just wasn't good for me so amazing i
mean i
actually it's funny because christine
and i the other day we were looking at
this woman that
did like this ketogenic diet it worked
for her but i've seen other people
have done it and it totally does the
opposite and so that i feel like that's
so important that people start to know
their bodies more
and see what works for them because you
could be doing something and then you
little did you know
you had a total hormonal imbalance which
is so i mean that that really changes
everything throughout your day to day
you nailed it yep that's exactly it so
it's all about trial and error
and just listening to your body and and
ultimately
you know trying to figure out what is
best for you right
definitely sophie and i are really big
fans of intermittent fasting
oh nice to do that so we every single
day we'll have dinner at 5
30 and people think that we sound like a
bunch of old ladies eating
eating dinner so early but we've found
that it's helped so much and then we
just
mix in a little bit of light workouts
between that and it's just
because i was pescatarian for a year and
i really loved the way i was looking and
i felt energized and it was amazing
but then i started to lack so much iron
and i was tired all the time
and i felt depleted so i totally agree
listen to your body and
and find what works for you um well
we're going to wrap it up we
so appreciate you guys coming on today i
need to get that chili pad asap
this whole time we've been writing down
a list of things that we're going to
order right after this
we're so excited i definitely want to go
check out your
infrared mat because that sounds
incredible why don't you tell all the
listeners where they can find
your website your products your socials
all of that yeah totally
um you definitely want to follow us um
so we're higherdos.com
we have an instagram it's a higher dose
if you want to follow
katie or myself she's at kt
caps and i'm at lauren burlingary um
you definitely want to follow the higher
dose instagram to see when products are
released but if you
want even more information sign up for
our newsletter because that's where
you're going to get even more amazing
information
amazing thank you guys so so so so much
and i hope you guys all check out their
website and their instagram pages to
learn more
bye guys thank you thanks ladies bye bye
thank you guys so much from all of us
here at the show thanks for staying
unwaxed be sure to download new episodes
every tuesday
on apple podcasts spotify or
podcastone.com
follow your hosts at sophia stallone and
at sistine stallone
and be sure to follow the show at
unwaxed podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week
you